[Music]
okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to getting
over it with bennett foddy
i'm currently home which means one
thing that my save game file didn't come
with me
and i have to start getting over it all
the way
back from the very very beginning so i'm
going to start this game doing something
that i should have done a long time ago
which is at the very heart of the matter
i should have just thrown myself in the
ocean
and drowned but now that i've done that
i can carry on now the thing about this
game is i'm
i'm a bit good at it by now i should be
right if i wasn't going if i wasn't good
at it now
then i'm not doing something right right
so i've i
better be good at it or else i ah
shooty tooties see i've got a new mouse
as well
come on
[Music]
can you shut up do i have to listen to
your drivel this whole goddamn time mr
bennett foddy
okay yeah shut up okay so he's gonna oh
thanks for coming with me on this trip
no no no no no no i know i played it
i know i know oh yeah games are rough
assemblages of foundation shut up
designers slap them shut up shut up shut
up i just want to get back to where i
was
it's built almost entirely out of found
and received shut up
shut up i don't care oh i don't care
about your philosophical drudgery
the frustration is just essential to the
act of climbing and it's authentic to
the process
of building a game about shut up how do
i shut you up
just shut up good god
up who's calling me
[ __ ] off why why now when i just
freaking
oh my god this is a new mouse too so
it's oh
there's a muscle twitching in my
forehead right here
i've never ever ever felt that muscle
before in my life why am i stuck
why am i stuck why am i stuck why am i
stuck
oh you guys don't understand what's
going on right now with my mouse
this is a mouse that is number one it's
broken
it's been broken for years i used to
raid with this mouth
in world of war oh i was right there i i
was right there
i was right there it was right there
just give it to me
i used to raid with this mouse and it's
broken
and come on i
i don't have another mouse that's the
thing i don't have another mouse
cause all of my mice that i have right
now that i brought with me
are freaking oh no oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god just gotta
i why am i even talking right now i
shouldn't have even started the episode
because i'm not anywhere where i once
was
oh my god i am feeling every ounce of it
all over all all over again why why i
where am i going you stay you stay
hard this mouse is range it's just
it's corded and the cord is like
snagging on something
and i don't like it okay
oh god stop dribbling stop dribbling
okay
see the cord is [ __ ] see that
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] did i just unplug it
no
no no you must die
[ __ ] no uh
wait why is my mouse visible now wait
what
what wha why can't i see my mouse now
what what
what the hecking hell wait
what no no
no what
what did why did that happen see this is
what i mean the mouse is broken it will
dis
why is what
well the obvious answer is just no no
it gonna start over again i'm not gonna
play with that because that's gonna mess
me up i don't know why
don't ask me why it's gonna mess me up
but it's just gonna mess me up and i
don't want that
no come no
what the heck in hell you don't do that
to me
i do that to my enemies not not
you do that i why did i go
so that way see i'm pretty good at the
game okay i
i'm pretty i'm pretty good at the game
no
pretty good to the game
no why am i here now
nope why did you no
oh my god
[Music]
oh no there we go
there we go that's more stuff it that's
more like the stuff
of it no that's not the it of stuff
no yes oh maybe so
oh yeah okay god is that [ __ ] still
blabbering on and on and on
about his inhaling [ __ ] oh
philosophical
philosophy
there we go okay
i don't know if i can get through this
part it's one that drives me
crazy crazy crazy
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh no oh no
what did you do now now
why did you do that you sack of [ __ ] you
sack of [ __ ] you sack of
[ __ ] you sack of [ __ ] you sack of [ __ ]
you sack of [ __ ] i'm not even back i
just wanted to get up to that one point
and then i would have been like
hey this is a good this is pretty much
where i was were
that's what i wanted to no no no
no that's what i wanted to know and then
then i would have been [ __ ]
what were you doing there what did you
decided to do there why did you just
slam me whammy you're bammy whammy on
that thing
don't you frick [ __ ] with me
climbing no why nothing why nothing why
would
what you want to explain that to me
no why are you doing away you're getting
really dancy wants you with this toilet
here
and i don't much appreciate that ha
okay
i love this game be a good little boy
and behave
be a good little boy and behave
be a good little boy in a black cauldron
be a good
little boy and behave
okay all right c c c
c i'm almost back to where i was which
is good
which is very good very good
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the stuff oh yeah
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah ah don't do
the pull thingy
oh don't do the push thingy okay don't
do the push
don't do the pull don't do anything at
all okay
ah we're back to the midpoint of the
live stream
that i had before okay i'm gonna turn
the vo back on because at least this
stuff i haven't heard 10 bajillion times
no that was that was uh oh oh
oh oh
okay there you go there's that that's
fun okay
it feels like we're closer now oh shut
up loser and climber shut up designer
and use it
you could have refused but you didn't
there was something in you that was
hidden
that chose to continue yeah i could have
refused yeah i
i could have refused are you
are you really that knee-deep in your
own sack of [ __ ] you think that i could
have
you could think i gotta refuse this no
i could not have refused this if i even
wanted to
they wouldn't have let me they you
wouldn't have let me designer
and audi
no no come on
behave wait a minute there
ye bronco okay you broncos stonko you
just behave yourself
no all right on the tip top of your
nosey whelp
no apparently the answer is not
you're trash can you not it is
literally a level playing field you
could just not slip slide like a dick
swimming pool no well if that's new okay
we'll just slip right off then we'll
just slip right
no
[Laughter]
there we go there we go no don't slippy
slop off the hat
come on what is that the sloppy toppy
from west of loathing
[ __ ] hell you were right there you
dick waggler
really really that's the kind of
[ __ ]
that makes me fall all the way back to
the bottom and it makes me hate you
that's the kind of [ __ ] that does that
so don't do that no
no no no why no no
no literally do nothing that you're
doing this is the
easy part this is the easy part
no god damn it
no god damn it stop this is the
easy part come on
god damn it just oh just go
no no no no no
no oh god
just climb it just
climb it why am i getting caught up on
the easy [ __ ]
come on that was the one
oh stop bouncing off you
[ __ ] waggler why is this suddenly
impossible
why in the [ __ ] world
is this suddenly impossible for me
god there's just no way huh there's just
no way huh
it just don't happen anymore huh
oh it just don't happen anymore no no no
it don't happen anymore no i don't have
the key anymore no no no no
i don't have the golden ticket no more
no
no no charlie's chocolate factory is
closed off to me
that did not do it no no that one
that one is a negative on that one
that's a big old
no really oh that's a nobo
yeah sure i'll slide all the way back to
no i'm not going to get on that fucker's
nose
good god good now
uh no oh my god i just spilled a goddamn
drink i don't understand what's
happening right now
at this one juncture i
am right here it's nothing's changed
i made it this far with relative
ease and suddenly
suddenly suddenly
i don't know why but things have
suddenly
decided to be the biggest dick
oh my god oh my god
i'm taking my time with this [ __ ]
i am taking my
i don't even know if the recordings will
work maybe my computer's gonna crash
maybe the microphone is broken but i'm
done with this one for now so thank you
everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think down in the
comments below and i'll get to the top
of this mountain soon so
thanks again and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]